Et bien bonjour et bienvenue dans cette deuxième vidéo sur le Japon !
Nous sommes actuellement à Fujinomiya
C'est un peu... la campagne
J'avais jamais vu la campagne japonaise bah... là j'y suis.
Et vu que les hôtels ça nous saoulait, comme vous pouvez le voir on va dormir dans une...
Caravane aménagée.
Attention petit tour des lieux
TA-TA-TA-TAAAA
Ici il y a juste un lac qui est de l'autre coté qui s'appelle le Lac Tanuki
Qui est très très beau !
C'est parti pour chiller pendant 24h
Bon, vu qu'il n'y a rien à faire
Nous sommes passés à un magasin
Et j'ai acheté tous les jouets que le magasin proposait
Et des jouets japonais !
- Des jouets japonais !
- Ah ! Celui là, celui là il est obscur !
Je sais pas ce que c'est !
- Ça fait des bulles ?
- Ah oui.
Mais pourquoi il y en a autant ?
Ouuuh, t'as le meilleur outil
C'était l'un des plus beaux moment du Japon... de ma vie
Attends mais c'est pourri moi, mec !
Ho mais vas - y fait péter, il est trop bien le tien !
*Musique stylée*
- Alors
- Mais mec!! T'es obligé de tout me balancer dessus comme un gros chien?
*Cris de Squeezie*
Ok ! Jeu suivant, Florent.
Attention
Oh nan, je me suis gourré, j'ai acheté deux fois le jeu avec les bulles...
- On peux faire une battle de games de bulles du coup ...
Qu'est ce qui s'est passé ?
On est au Japon, le Japon c'est quoi ? C'est Nintendo, Nintendo c'est quoi ? C'est Pokemon
Je t'ai enchainé, c'était super chiant.
Bon, on veut tous Drakofeu ?
Si c'est Dracofeu, ça va te brûler les mains normalement
AAAAAAAAAAAH
C'est quoi ça ? C'est un pokémon ou c'est une appli mobile qui poulie pokémon ?
qui copie pokémon pardon*
Alors ça c'est génial !
On s'croirait chez mamie quand on avait 8 ans !
Florent : Et encore à l'époque on avait des Gameboys..
Squeezie : Mais y'avait pas ce Pokémon !
Aaaaah, ça mamie elle m'en achetait au marché.
Florent, Florent, Florent !
(Le désespoir)
P*tain...
Touche, c'est la pire matière du monde
Florent : Aaaaaaaaaaah
Squeezie : Oh merde !
Squeezie : Attend
Florent : Attend
Squeezie : Oh putain pas loin !
Eh mais moins fort toi !
Raté.
Maintenant c'est l'heure de passer au dernier jouet : c'est un nerf Japonais.
*Cris d'enthousiasme*
Squeezie: Tu t'es pas fait mal en tombant ?
- Si
*rires*
Ehhhhhh, mais que voilà..
Aïe, oh mais p*tain mais starfoullah, il s'passe quoi dans cet endroit là ?!
Une pokéball et on a, OH !
PU-TAIN !
Bon on vient d'ouvrir tous les jeux, ça nous a occupé 30 minutes
On va faire un Uno tranquillement et puis j'sais pas c'qu'on va faire
Aller au revoir !
*Boite à musique douce*
Bonjour très chers amis. Il est actuellement 6h14 du matin
Je me lève pour pouvoir aller filmer au drone
le lever du soleil, au dessus du mont Fudji
Tout est prêt, sauf mon cerveau qui est encore en train de dormir
Alors allons-y !
Pu-tain on a trop de chance, aujourd'hui il fait méga beau
On va pouvoir admirer le mont Fujdi mais comme jamais !
Ok je l'ai devant moi, c'est totalement impressionant
Le mont Fudji
C'est tellement ouf d'avoir un truc aussi imposant devant soi
J'ai toujours l'impression, quand j'vois des trucs aussi gros , que c'est des photographies
qu'on a mit devant moi.
Ou qu'c'est juste une plaque de contreplaqué géante
et on a peint un truc dessus.
*musique douce*
(C'est beau n'est-ce pas?)
Et voilà, j'espère que ce petit réveil en compagnie du mont Fudji vous aura plû
On va pas tarder à bouger vers notre prochaine destination
à savoir Hakoné
À tout à l'heure !
Surprise ! Nous venons d'arriver à Hakoné
Dans notre ryokan !
C'est un hôtel de type tradition
Autrement appelé quand tu sais parler français un hôtel traditionnel
Du coup c'est vraiment ambiance Japon
à base de petites portes coulissantes
à base de petites tables basses basses
Mais surtout, à base de onsen sur la terrasse !
Est-ce qu'on se met pas tous cul nu les Hauchard ?
Au programme on fait quoi ?
Florent : On essaie les katanas !
Les katanas ? Qu'est-ce que tu racontes ?
Ah les... merde... les yukatas !
C'est raciste monsieur ! Là vous êtes presque raciste *rires*
Un yukata mon cher Florent ! Eh oui !
- Et oui Jamy !
Et il s'agit de la tenue traditionnelle... pour homme !
Bonjour maître Thierry !
- Eh !
Vous maniez le kung fu ?
- Le kung fu !
(C'est un bon style)
Oh ! Mon Dieu ! Ici on a un moine en train de pratiquer le yoga
Mais qu'il est beau p*tain!
*Musique Japonaise*
On aurait dit que c'était fait exprès
Nous sommes le matin, et aujourd'hui
Nous allons à Yokohama, c'est la dernière
destination du voyage avant Tokyo.
Oh! J'entends un Hauchard se lever attention
Bonjour
Allez, ça dégage !
Bon, là les amis il faut être au petit déjeuner dans 30 minutes
Mais en attendant,
Je propose tout simplement :
(HUUU) !!! D'avoir extrêmement froid
Le temps de rentrer dans se que l'on appelle
AAAAHHHH... Nusen
Excellent jeu de mot même au Japon
*OHHHH*
C'est chaud! Mais ça brûle!
Je vais vous mettre là
On est bien là! On est ambiance tamisée-posée
Et donc en fait à Hakoné, il y a plein de sources naturelles d'eau chaude
Il y en a 7 je crois
Et le onsen, comme dans cet hôtel, pompe dans ces sources chaudes
Et il amène l'eau ici
Ce qui fait que c'est chauffé naturellement et qu'il y a du souffre dans l'eau
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a le froid? Qu'est ce que tu vas faire?
Il y a des singes, qui se sont appropriés certaines sources d'eau chaude
Maintenant ils vivent dedans
Du coup, au lieu d'aller te baigner dans un bain en pleine nature, tu peux aller regarder les singes se baigner dans un bain en pleine nature
Bon aller c'est parti pour Yokohama
Bienvenue à Yokohama! Ville portuaire. Assez proche de Tokyo (40 minutes en train)
J'ai révisé, ouai
On vient d'arriver le premier truc que l'on va faire c'est de prendre un bâteau
Pour aller à : China Town!
Parce que le quartier chinois de Yokohama et tout simplement ouf
Allez c'est parti
Et voici la porte du quartier chinois!
Squeezie : 3 choses qu'on trouve dans un quartier chinois
Florent : Des Chinois
Des Sin-Chinois
Les Hauchard
Eh ben voilà! On a nos 3 choses bien joué!
*rires*
*musique japonaise*